[Música]
tuvieron no tuvimos esa es la pregunta
sacada de una obra de shakespeare de
hamlet que tiene de algún tema
existencial que lo que vamos a platicar
un poquito hoy tuvo horno tuvo para la
pena y la universidad o no vale la pena
ir a la universidad considerando lo que
está pasando hoy
la típica gráfica que siempre te
presenta en ese estado
de la gente que se ha salido de que si
exitosa dice si yo tienes a bill gates
así por ejemplo igual vamos a bien pero
a los diez años dejó la escuela y
construir todo un imperio choco talero
vale la pena o no vale la pena estudiar
éste está muy simple porque para llegar
a ese éxito poner estas ciertas
condiciones y en las cosas que sucedan
para poder llegar estar ahí pero les
presento a alguien más local igual lo
conocen a julián ríos un leandro se
empezó a los 13 años a desarrollar una
solución para detectar el cáncer de seno
por qué porque a su mamá le dio cáncer
escena tú se puso estudiar junto con
tres amigos temas de algoritmos y tema
de sensores y puede desarrollar un
producto que se llama eba que ahorita ya
está en el mercado hoy julián está
fundado por stanford university y por
unique lo micro es una compañía japonesa
de ropa muy exitosa y está ahorita
haciendo las pruebas finales para
lanzarse al mercado de un producto que
va a ser muy exitoso que va a poder
detectar mejor el cáncer de seno que
como lo detecta hoy la mastografía
19 años piso la universidad falta de
monterrey que salió y estuvo un semestre
en la universidad monterrey no estoy
llega a la universidad para entender de
inteligencia artificial y para entender
de sensores no para armar todo un
business case el solo entonces vale la
pena o no la pena ir a la universidad y
además nos toca un tiempo bastante
interesante les toca a ustedes vivir un
tiempo muy interesante que el famoso
busca ubica en español su mundo volátil
es un mundo incierto es un mundo
complejo y es un mundo bastante ambiguo
y las reglas del juego cambian en cada
momento se está modificando es la única
constante este mundo cambia y cambia lo
que estamos viendo hoy el trump y el
rédito esperanza lo que estamos viviendo
son sobre éxito incluso son temas de
gente que quiere dar dos pasos atrás
porque tenemos miedo al tema la
incertidumbre nos sentimos más cómodos
como estábamos antes y esto lo está
generando los cambios tecnológicos que
están dando
masiva por la democratización del
conocimiento antes el conocimiento
estaba en las universidades hoy el
conocimiento está en la red no necesitas
ir a la universidad para acceder al
conocimiento
entonces qué pasa voy a perder mi
trabajo en el año 2032 qué quiere decir
esto básicamente lo que quiere decir es
que el 67 por ciento de los trabajos se
van a inventar en los próximos años hoy
no existen toda la universidad no se
puede preparar para un trabajo que ni
siquiera va a existir el 47% de los
trabajos que existen hoy se han
automatizar para el año 2032
y hay un estudio de la university que
dice que básicamente que el 50 por
ciento de lo que aprendas en la
universidad en 5 años va a ser obsoleto
entonces vale la pena no vale la pena ir
la universidad y si vamos a que vamos en
ese sentido entonces clave esto esto
esto es lo que me tocó vivir la parte de
arriba de la gráfica esto me tocó a mí
vivirlo tú te educadas sacarás un título
y la empresa te daba trabajo porque
tenías un título y luego éste ya
trabajas en la empresa en mi empresa por
el don de trabajo yo tengo 23 años
trabajando en las empresas las empresas
ya no viven tanto las empresas hace 20
años su promedio de vida de 60 años y
ahorita las empresas su promedio de vida
es de 15 años y cada año va bajando el
promedio bien todas las empresas van
cambiando porque en economías van
cambiando las tecnologías van cambiando
en ese sentido entonces veamos esto
comparemos nuestro cerebro como si fuera
mi smartphone y me voy a referir a de
veces a esto entonces el tema es que la
universidad lo que te daba te daba
aplicación estaba apps para llegar al
mundo y pueden aplicar esas apps este
que tuvieran valor para las empresas
sucedió lo que hacía es agarrar a mí app
y de vez en cuando la actual y zabala
actualizadas cada cuatro o cinco años
nada más pero era una actualización no
tenía que volver pasar pasar por la por
la universidad y con eso podía
sobrevivir sin ningún problema en ese
tiempo cuando el conocimiento está
avanzando tan rápido hay aplicación que
aún sirve en el momento que el que las
tienes no era ni siquiera meses cuando
él así es que tirar otra vez entonces en
la gráfica de abajo te ilustran que
estamos hablando de una universidad de
por vida
eso habla salvador alva ahorita el
presidente de una universidad de por
vida que quiere decir que vamos a estar
tocando constantemente el conocimiento
en ese sentido porque todo lo demás se
va a estar se va a estar os electrizando
entonces bueno qué caso tiene ir a la
universidad si voy a estar yendo a cada
rato pues mejor movida course era éste
agarró ahorita había un curso de
stanford que está buenísimo the machine
learning que no tengo que la universidad
y me lo da un profesor de stanford sí y
pago una ínfima parte de lo que pagaría
este en universidad para agarrar ese ese
curso
pero el tema el tema diferente es si las
universidades insisten en enfocarse en
las aplicaciones van a perder
completamente su alumnado
hay un estudio también de clayton
christensen del harvard business school
que dice este chavo que en 15 años la
mitad de las universidades en eeuu en ir
a la bancarrota y está pasando ahí hay
mucho recomiendo es cual es que este año
se fueron a la bancarrota porque se
quedaron sin alumnos y porque se
quedaron sin alumnos porque hizo que
porque voy a pagar yo por algo que luego
cuando salgas resulta que el mercado se
lo está demandando no tienen utilización
pero el tema el tema es que las
universidades
se vende clavar en el ios en el sistema
operativo como aprendemos nosotros
precisamente aprender a desaprender y
aprender mucho más rápido en ese en este
sentido entonces bueno vamos a ir más
años vamos a estar más conocimiento hay
un estudio que está dice que en promedio
ustedes van a cambiar 17 veces de
trabajo y van a trabajar en cinco
industrias diferentes 5 industria
diferentes alguno de los padres ustedes
jamás cambio de trabajo entonces subió
en ese sentido
viene el tema de todo 4.0 lo que se
necesita hoy lo que están demandando
antes demanda un tema de profundidad de
conocimiento con industria 3.0 y ahorita
con 4.0 lo que demanda el sistema
operativo es precisamente cómo podemos
tener learning agility cómo podemos
aprender rápido cómo podemos tener
empatía y cómo podemos tener
adaptabilidad
entonces antes medidas hace 50 años se
media el coeficiente intelectual la
gente creía que éste subía agua al
tinaco quería decir que puedes tener una
chamba entonces se enfocaba mucho si es
listo la va a ser luego sacaron hace 20
años no nada más es coeficiente
intelectual es coeficiente emocional o
sea no nada más es que les robaba el
tinaco sino que se puede llevar con los
demás sí que puede armar equipos de
trabajo ahora el tema que se está
midiendo es no nada más es coeficiente
emocional es coeficiente de
adaptabilidad qué tan adaptable puede
ser qué tan rápido te puedes mover en
ese sentido entonces vale la pena ir a
universidad yo digo que si vale la pena
si sólo si vas a construir estas
competencias que son las competencias
transversales no te enfoques tanto en la
aps enfoque temas en el sistema
operativo
este es un ejemplo de una diversidad que
está cambiando todo su currículum es una
universidad chiquita se llama bikers
college está massachusetts hay pocas que
se están moviendo a esta velocidad y
otro después de este en canadá este que
he podido encontrar que el tema se llama
este mindset ágil ver cómo mover más
rápido ya qué me refiero con mindset
ágil deja de platicarles los músculos
que tendríamos que construir si
decidimos ir a la universidad este
chaval se llama the sting zhang ling
igual ya lo han visto este tiene ahí
su página en youtube etcétera etcétera
esa bicicleta de la creo esa bicicleta
tiene la característica de que si tú le
das a la izquierda se va para la derecha
tituladas para la derecha se va a la
izquierda este chavo este sabía andar en
bicicleta y dijo yo quiero aprender a
andar la bicicleta de manera diferente
entonces éste hizo estos cambios y tardó
ocho meses en volver a aprender a andar
de bicicleta
de este modo neuroplasticidad se llama
qué quiere decir este tema de cómo
puedes aprender cosas cargamos nuestro
disco duro cargamos nuestro smartphone
como te deshaces de esas cosas que no te
van a servir como metes otras cosas
diferentes que sí que sí van a ser
utilidad cómo construyes este músculo de
agilidad hay varias formas éste está
chava
de singularity university bueno esto no
es una chava pero
es este un saltamontes dice dice
básicamente tu mente sus saltamontes en
un bote le pones una tapa eventualmente
el saltamontes deja de brincar de saltar
le quita la tapa y ya no vale saltar en
su vida aunque no haya tapa quiere decir
es el tema de la creatividad o nosotros
éramos niños éramos muy creativos el
sistema escolar mató a la mayor parte de
nuestra creatividad la creatividad es
esencial en esta nueva economía que
viene la hija de la creatividad la
curiosidad no se preocupen tanto por lo
que aprenden sino por lo que preguntan
steve jobs basaba toda toda su
estrategia en base de preguntas si
puedes hacer en el número de cosas
descubrir el mundo a base de preguntas
que tiene que ver con la curiosidad y la
creatividad es importantísima en esta
nueva economía escuchar importante él es
parte de la curiosidad porque el que
pregunta pues obviamente tiene tiene que
escuchar me da la atención la sobrina
mía que vio ahora en melwood que estaba
en intercambios y la veo y plática me
cuántas nacionalidades has conocido no
funciona y posee minutos san pedro para
acá
estepona down todos juntos para que
nissan el boom osea que aprendiste lo
que querías agarrar diferente porque al
final de cuentas la neuroplasticidad se
construye en base a ver puntos de vista
diferentes multidisciplinaridad poder
ver las cosas de diferentes ángulos
necesitamos también resolver problemas
complejos
esos son esos son los músculos
transversales que tenemos que ir
construyendo cómo puedo resolver
problemas complejos
multidisciplinar esencial y en el cuales
hay en el número de oportunidades para
para hacer esto trabaje en cosas que no
sean tu zona de confort métete en
actividades que no tengan que ver
necesariamente con el app el app cuando
salgas no va a servir probablemente que
el aprenderé la app te sirva
precisamente para construir esta parte
transversal en conclusión
pero no vayas
pero no vayas por el título ve pero no
vayas por el app ve pero no vayas por el
conocimiento per se la universidad es
excelente para construir estos músculos
transversales que tiene que ver con
creatividad que tiene que ver este con
la parte de learning que agilite en ese
en ese sentido entonces este ahora que
van ustedes mucho ustedes van para para
college vayan por esos músculos
transversales
vale la pena eso es lo que vale la pena
en ese sentido y por el puro título ni
vayan es una perdedera de tiempo y de
dinero muchas gracias
[Aplausos]